and joe biden the u.s president has said
that putin in his words cannot remain in
power
i mean no matter how horrific you know
the war crimes that russia has been
committing is it right for the u.s
president to be effectively calling for
regime change
well the united states us and the united
kingdom and our nicer allies have been
clear what we think about
the action that russia has taken in
ukraine
the labour party entirely supports the
work that we're doing internationally in
the nato alliance we support what the
united states is doing this is why we
want to go as far as far as we possibly
can on sanctions
on russia
i'll leave the comments that the
president of the united states has made
to the subject for the white house to
to to clarify i think they put out
comments about that but we have to do
all we can to impose the maximum
pressure on russia who sanctions
we've obviously pushed the government to
go further and faster
but we also need to do what we can to
support the ukraine with what assistance
and and to listen carefully to what
ukraine are calling for in terms of
assistance and we need to ensure that
there's humanitarian support as well
particularly around refugees and
and it's great that we can that the
british people have shown such
generosity in signing up to the refugee
program but but we still have too much
bureaucracy in place and we need to do
all we can to take to take the refugees
that we obviously ought to take
okay and you talk there about the need
to step up assistance to do all we can
and but i think it's important to get
into specifics isn't it because the easy
bit is saying that we need to do
everything we can we need to look at
what ukraine is asking for and president
zielinski has called on european
countries to do more hasn't he so what
specifically do you think the uk can
actually do in your view
well we've obviously already offered uh
uh equipment uh we need to our our
defense experts will want to consider
carefully other requests for that for
equipment and make a judgment about what
is appropriate
we in the labour party have supported
the government on that and will continue
to support the government in whatever
decisions that they need to take with
in that respect but we also need to do
more on the humanitarian side as well i
mean there is so much bureaucracy in
place which is prohibiting the
ability for british families to take to
taking refugees as they have been asked
to do and have signed up and are wanting
to do so there's a number of things
where we need to move further and faster
but there is no division between the
labour party and the people of ukraine
and the labour party and and our
commitment to nato and our commitment to
doing the right thing in this awful
conflict
okay um we just heard from the education
secretary there's lots going on
domestically as well with the course of
living emergency effectively rather than
a crisis that is a you know hitting the
united kingdom
um firstly just to clear something up
you wha when rishi shinak gave his a
spring statement and after he'd finished
unveiling that support there was a kind
of a loud voice from the labour benches
shouting is that it was that you
yes it was me and the reason that was me
is because i thought rishi sunak in what
was a incredibly in what is an
incredibly serious time we just talked
about ukraine failed to rise to the
moment failed to deliver for the british
people look as a consequence of the
decisions that rishi sunak and these
conservative mps have made
the state pension will be cut in real
terms by the biggest amount for 50 years
the tax burden is going to be the
highest since the 40s the collapsing
living standards the most dramatic since
the 50s later this week the universal
credit will be cut in real terms
disability benefits will be cut in real
terms and that means over a million
people pushed into poverty many
pensioners pushed into poverty five
hundred thousand children pushed into
absolute poverty and there'll be people
watching the show this morning
who can't who are struggling with their
bills who can't fill up their car whose
cupboards are bare whose fridges are
empty whose children are hungry and
rishi sunak thinks that's a price worth
paying while we in the labour party
don't
is the problem though um
money effectively i don't think anyone
would disagree about the
the concern that you have expressed
there about how families aren't going to
cope you know in the months and years
ahead but you know you want more money
for pensioners more money for the nhs
after covered because time has called
for more defense bet spending obviously
more money to tackle the cost of living
emergency through energy bills through
benefits
and and i know that you're going to
we'll start talking about the
chancellor's you know windfall because
of increased tax revenues but things are
of course very volatile as well i mean
the cost of borrowing for example has
quadrupled in the last year is it not
important for the government to also
maintain some fiscal discipline
well wichita obviously had more room for
maneuver in this spring statement in
this mini budget but but rather than
acting in the interest of the british
people
he was playing games he was acting in
his own interest because he thinks by
offering an income tax cut in two years
that will help him politically with
conservative mps if there's a leadership
contest or that will fit the tory
election grade
i don't believe that putting 1.3 million
people into poverty because you're
imposing a very severe real terms cut to
universal credit you're imposing the
biggest cut to the pension in 50 years
is fair
government is about choices and he could
have taken a different set of choices he
could have imposed a windfall tax on
those monumental profits the gas and oil
companies have made and use that
windfall tax to help struggling families
and pensioners with their energy bills
he chose not to do that instead he's
imposed these very punishing tax rises
these very severe real terms cuts to the
pension and support like universal
credit and he's expecting people to be
grateful because two years down the road
he's saying there may there's going to
be an income tax cut even though that
income tax cut nowhere near offsets the
15 tax rises that he has imposed on the
british people 3 000 pounds extra per
household if you do if you do a rough
and ready calculation he is a tax rising
chancellor he is mr tax and it's the
british people who are paying the price
well it's pretty clear that rishi sunak
has seen his most difficult set of
headlines this week and i think that
goes without saying
who would you prefer to face in an
election boris johnson or rishi sunak
yeah you know something i mean i i i'm
not i don't care that rishi sunak is
facing difficult headlines i'm more
concerned about the difficult
circumstances british pensioners are
facing the difficult circumstances that
families often in work
are facing with the cost of living as i
say not able to afford their heating
bills cutting back on hot meals that's
what pensioners tell me that they're not
using their oven because they don't want
they cannot afford the bills associated
with heating their oven or forgoing hot
showers because they can't afford the
bills associated with running hot water
that is what concerns me that is what
makes me angry that for the f the
biggest real terms cut in the pension
for 50 years and rishi sunath thinks
that's a price worth paying if he gets
bad headlines as a consequence of that
you know quite rightly because he is he
is
pushing people into poverty because he
thinks by being clever that allows him
to cut tax in a couple of years time
income tax ahead of a general election
that's not right it's not a price worth
paying
okay now
let's just move on because i'm quite
keen to talk to you a little bit about
kovich obviously work and pensions
brief at the minute but you were shadow
house secretary uh throughout the air
pandemic
so just put that hat back on briefly
covert cases are rising uh we're seeing
and around one in 16 people thought to
have the virus
how worried should we be about that
well i always said that living with
covid is not the same as ignoring covid
but i also said that there'll come a
point where because of our advances in
vaccination because of our advances in
anti-viral medicines that would be able
to move away from the restrictions that
sadly had to be in place
two years ago i think when you look at
where the infection rates appear to be
higher again some of the cities like
birmingham and leeds their second dose
rates on vaccinations are still in the
sort of 70 region so we've still got
further to go on vaccination it is not
job done on vaccination so i'd really
encourage the government to put in place
more support at a local level to drive
up those vaccination rates the second
thing of course is i remember before we
went into lockdown i went into downing
street to meet boris johnson and chris
whittie and dominic cummings and others
had separate meetings as well with matt
hancock to discuss the upcoming
legislation that would impose these very
severe restrictions we supported those
restrictions in the national interest
but we also said that people would need
economic support and from those
negotiations came an agreement that
statutory sick pay would be paid from
day one okay that day one statutory
sickbay has now been stopped well if
people are getting ill they will need
sick pay from day one so i would urge
the government to reintroduce statutory
sick pay from day one
um we have run out of time but just to
quickly ask you uh your thoughts uh
after the duke and duchess of
cambridge's caribbean tour uh prince
william acknowledged growing republican
sentiment saying it's brought into even
sharper focus questions about the past
and the future
and he's not about telling people what
to do do you think this could be the end
of the commonwealth
no i i don't think the commonwealth will
and i think the commonwealth will enjoy
but obviously individual nations will
always make their own judgments and come
to their own decisions about their
membership of the commonwealth but i'm
i'm i feel i'm absolutely convinced that
the commonwealth will survive and will
endure and uh and
and that's for the good
okay thank you very much for being on
the program today jonathan ashwest from
labour